colleagues candidates agents I'm happy
to move on to the second declaration a
result of poll for the election of a
member of parliament for Coventry North
East on Thursday the 8th of June 2017
I'm Martin Reeves being the acting
returning officer at the above election
do hereby give notice that the number of
votes recorded for each candidate at the
said election is as follows filled
Russell David Liberal Democrat 1157
Fletcher Killeen Margaret the Labour
Party candidate twenty nine thousand and
ninety nine Handley Matthew Stephen
green party
502 Mahmood half-cell independent 81
mayor Timothy James the Conservative
Party candidate 13 thousand nine hundred
and nineteen tiger after UK Independence
Party UK 1350 the total number of ballot
papers rejected was 128 and the turnout
for this constituency was 61 point five
six percent and I do hereby declare the
clean Margaret Fletcher is duly elected
[Applause]
who's so exciting
it's been a really long and tiring night
tonight so and everyone probably wants
to go home in a bit so I'll be as brief
as I can I'd like to start by thanking
the returning officer and all of the
counting stuff here tonight and for all
your hard work and the fantastic job
you've done this evening of course I
don't want to forget the security stuff
and everyone else here at the Ricoh I
pay particular tribute to each of my
fellow candidates although we are
political opponents and we fundamentally
disagree on many issues I believe it's
notable that despite our differences
we're still able to conduct our
campaigns in a respectful fair and
decent manner and I want to thank them
for that
I want to pay tribute to my campaign
team headed by the brilliant Damian
Gannon and to my fantastic agent faith
Abbott all of whom have worked so hard
over the last six or seven weeks to
ensure we repeat the success of 2015 in
Coventry North East your dedication
commitment and much-needed good humour
over the course of the campaign has been
inspiring and I'm hugely grateful for
everything that everyone has done for me
most importantly I want to thank the
good people of come to North East it's
been an absolute honor and a privilege
to serve as your local Member of
Parliament for the last two years and
it's truly humbling that you have once
again chosen to place your trust in me
to represent your interests and those of
our city in Parliament over the course
of the next few years
hopefully I promise that I will repay
the trust you've shown in me each and
every day I will fight for the good
quality jobs and investment and the
affordable homes that our city needs I
will fight to protect our public
services to secure the future of and
funding for our brilliant NHS and our
social care system to secure access to
good teaching in a good school for every
child and to secure more police officers
on our streets to keep our communities
safe
I will also fight for the interest of
the individual - and I promise to help
those struggling in tons of difficulty
hardship and crisis I'm extremely proud
to have been reelected as the Member of
Parliament for Coventry northeast this
is the community that I was born and
raised in and where I continue to live
with my family the fifth generation of
my family is now being brought up in
Coventry Northeast going to the schools
using the hospital's what happens in
Coventry is important to me as it is to
you and you can be assured that I will
always stand up for the interests of our
city and our community thank you very
much
you